come on get physical I was in
Toronto when you brought the cup
to uh Westwood how was you I don't
know it's not just about outscoring
teams it's about outplaying teams on
a cut back on for hand shoot to the
net get the [__] in that Call's
crashing nothing better than playing
in the NHL than winning in the NHL
called chemistry I got what is anybody here to
do has the moment sunk in that you're
facing your childhood Idol on your nhut
yet how much pressure does that create
in a situation like this how will you
measure your own success tonight how'd
you sleep last night like a baby suck good
Conor Bard going to make his debut tonight
it's always electricity opening night but
is there a little more juice in the building
when the first overall picks making his NHL
debut there's a lot of hype around this game
obviously it's a real bright young player that
will inevitably emerge as a superstar he likes
the big moments and I think this is going to be
a special night for us to all be involved and
uh I'm just happy to be uh in the first seat
right behind watching I bet he's really excited
to start against a guy likes it I just enjoy it
you know first NHL game that's what you dream
of and you know there's a lot of expectations
and a lot of things going on around you but
you know that's a game that you look back on
you know no matter what with a lot of great
memories so I think you just try to soak it
up and enjoy it PPG Paints Arena here in
Pittsburgh number one overall pick 2005
Sydney Crosby head to-head with number one
overall pick this year Conor Bard you got
to be hard on the boards all right fast through
the neutral zone and smart players at their blo
line and play in their Zone play their losss
all right we'll have a good night there all
right so to doing that we're going to start with
Taylor Conor and Ryan and blast Peter and the
ne the start of a new era in Chicago and
perhaps in the National Hockey League
as [Applause] [Music] well go f go dard and
Crosby about to take the opening face off in
a moment Conor Bard has been dreaming
about for a long time hey Sid welcome
back for another season Conor good luck man
welcome to the NHL man okay guys it's show
time let's have a great [Music] game go go
go go middle go [Music] middle net net net
net dang the right wing let tag to the front
[Applause] re the penguins have a one- nothing
lead hey rebound Bard had a great chance the
puck is free in the crease nice
pass I got the whole F going in
there hey hey hey same thing crossby
Center for gel back for s the kid he
scores it's 87 check it in on opening night
although this is going to be reviewed was
using a coach's challenge to determine if
the play was offside prior to the scoring
of the goal good huh good on oh yeah I
think so it looked all right to me when
I was up there I would think when I'm coming
up I'd see white if it was out you know I mean
it will be TJ luxmore the referee making the
call after review the play has been confirmed
to be on side count Sydney Crosby with his
first of the year 1156 the [Applause] time
now leaves it for L closing in down
the left side sh they score let's
go let go and Conor berard's got his first
National Hockey League [Applause] point
let's Go's go budy Conor Bard in his National
Hockey League debut has a point on the board
and Donato's got his first as a Chicago Blackhawk
and 40 minutes are complete penguins with a 2-1
lead against the Chicago Blackhawks I'm yet
to win a draw me yet to win a draw that is
that true I think I've tied like five but
really tough when you go against 87 he's
[Music] s centers Gutman scores Cole
Gutman has tied it at two with 955 to
go frantic action here in the third period
one timer one timer 820 to go here's Carlson
down low and another big stop by morzin kensel
looks Skyward he can't believe it here Center
iing over the penguin line left wing drops it
off put it over shot by dick and he scores and
the Hawks take a 3-2 lead over the Penguins
with 431 left in the third good job good
job I got it with the empty
net the C the Perry out in
front and they [Applause] score the
Blackhawks come into Pittsburgh and
score four straight Bard and the
Hawks an impressive win on opening
what are you going to remember most about tonight
uh the winning yeah for [Music] [Applause]
sure to get a point and to win how would you
summarize your debut yeah it was a lot of fun I
mean to get the win I think uh you know obviously
being down two and and coming back like we did I
think it's it's awesome for our group guys that
was work from uh from first a training camp all
the way through this game nothing better than
playing in the NHL than winning in the [Applause]
NHL what an atmosphere here at T-Mobile Arena
Chris Lee out there along with Wes mcau our
referees tonight gentlemen welcome
to the new NHL season this should be
Electric
as a coach you're focused on the the opponent
at hand tonight but I think we're all looking
forward to taking a couple of minutes to
look back and then put it behind us when
the puck drops and get going try to do it again
and I'm looking forward to it just like anybody
else [Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
everybody don't stop [Music] the don't stop
[Music] the [Applause]
down check
28 between the blue lines we got to
manage pucks right manage pucks make
the right decision with the puck angles
if you can't finish your check if you can
great we want to be physical if you can't
take a good angle don't let them beat you
up the ice into the good ice get to our
game in a hurry use everybody all playing
the same way Nick W your line will start
hagger petol and hilan nuts here go the
[Applause] first the Stanley Cup champions forming
up in the tunnel set to take the ice here at the
Fortress and now welcome to the ice with the
Stanley Cup captain Mark [Applause] St of all
the amazing shows you can see here in Las Vegas
no performance last year was better than that
of the golden knights they will celebrate their
Stanley Cup Championship tonight I guess it's a
memory now right just a great memory some of
the funnest hockey you know we will'll ever
play but it gives us a sense of urgency
right we want to be back there so we know
you're he not going to be given to us first
touch got to get it moving a gets this cor
check up up oh great stick
there stop on it Michael Carly
here Stevenson brings it AC cross out back
door the first shot off ends up behind through
[Applause]
I think they're almost trying to go behind
me and push me back and then go through the
middle so I'm going to kind of be in
between just let me know we're too far
[Music] up you're good higher higher wheel
wheel wheel wheel PA coner sends it in and
he cring behind the net sweeps one out
good job by T puts it in his own neck T
tried to carry it behind the cage play it
towards the net and it TS in two nothing
[Music]
Vegas good release good release he has him yeah
bar finish just a moment AG go tow drag between
the legs on net covered by gr Bower good block
good block by there guy sometimes you got sit
your C you know mnav skates onto it for the
golden knights oh beautiful Outlet pass the
barf who moves in Hook from behind what a pass
what a finish three nothing Vegas how do you fine
look for a stick there against this D sty here
hey in the corner it's thrown out in front that
shot score Jared mccan the 40 goal scorer from
the last season on the board on opening night
as are the Kraken as they try and fight their way
back in it hey everyone be ready hey they're going
to play two they're going to play two line so
we keep our Pace up they're going to get tired
too right here right here right
here Angelo F that shot whistles
wide hit by Chandler Stevenson eel for the empty
net SC the crowd at The Fortress celebrates a
banner raising and the standing cup to start
and they celebrate a 41 win on opening night
definitely excited to to start the year off uh
we're fortunate enough that we have mostly the
same team we've been through every situation and
uh it it was just one of those games that a lot of
things went well for us it's pretty cool watching
a you know Championship Banner get raised into the
rafters and knowing that uh you know you're part
of history and it's going to be there forever it
was a pretty cool moment and um you know nice to
be there with the guys and and uh share that with
them we're moving our feet we're competing
at a high level we got energy in here energy
on the bench energy on the ice that
drives the physicality we're more alert
we're more aware and our game just comes
together here on the road in the start of
a great trip C Lilly will go for us on
the back JT with nice and Willie Sammy
kicking a great atmosphere electricity in the
air here at Emirate Bank Arena been waiting
for this one it was so fun playing in front
of these fans the energy that they had for us
all of last year and coming into this season
has been amazing all right on the left we got
swaggy in the middle we got the Swiss Army KN
on the right we got Chucky on the back we have
Meeks the other back we got [__] and in the
net we have Bobby the Panthers playing their
home opener and it's a rematch of last season's
second round playoff series against the Toronto
Maple Leafs I think it's easy to get hung up
on the past cousins closing shooting scores
Nick cousins wins the series obviously you
know it's always in the back of your mind
the previous playoff uh stuff but uh in the end
it's you know you're focused on today and and
the here and now four consecutive years the
Panthers have made the Stanley Cup playoffs
and they're the Eastern Conference champions
there's a new Banner in the house it's go wakey
wakey wake come on and we are underway y y take
him take him you know really uh good friend of
mine you know play with him at the US team and
you know World Juniors and to see him do what
he's doing it's very very impressive and proud
of him he's done a great job and he's off to
another hell of a start this year we got to get
to the ins too much on the outside already boys
oh he's an extremely effective
talented player and uh he does
a lot of uh really great things for for
his team you know in a lot of different
ways so he's always a challenge to
playing against quick go go pause
hold it's a battle for that loose Pockets kep
to the outside by kingberg given away right
Circle a shot and they score yeah and it's Kevin
stanlin with a heavy wrist shot out of the right
Circle and the Panthers are on the board final
seconds see how they're doing this behind the
net boys barov looking at give someone a chance
Ean Larson shoots he scores o e l two nothing
Panthers [Applause] yes hard boys hard go go let's
get hit physical here hey come on get physical you
three get physical finish finish him move that
move that good work boys keep working let's go
shoot some pucks here get the Pucks in the net
Call's crashing DD Rim I'll take care Miner's
back at the net finds nander in front for tarus
the shot right down the back hand scores mner
boys and the Maple Leafs are on the board that's
the races now is looks ahead to Gregor buting it
on binz Gregor penalty coming now the Nets
off Le thought that might be a penalty shot
no he's with you the whole way I would yeah no
he's with through the whole way though but if
you break away then yeah like if you get a step
on him but I don't think you had a step I want
to make sure that the puck doesn't go in the
normal positions of the post here as a result
of Florida knocking the net off yeah this is a
better angle to see if the puck is going to go
in the net here as a result I don't think it
does okay we're good upon further video review
the call on the ice stands we have no goal and
we have a penalty for tripping against Florida
2-1 Panther lead should be a great third period
you got nothing Onre try to get open for in the
corner I'll jump off the net need to kill this
boys shoot Koski makes the stop we got to win
those there we need that puck we need that P you
got it I think if I have to a little bit like just
spread out a little bit so I can bump it like I
did then we can spread him out and work it now
another a chance on the side of the over brosi
turn it away from Marr yeah if you're going to
if you're going to spin shoot it to the net on
a cut back on forehand shoot it to the net it's
probably the best game that we've played in in
terms of the quality of the game it was it was
tight it was fast it was competitive back for
Mar a chance for to at the Go post I know what
you're trying to do but he's right there and you
make a left and make a right I have to shut it
down didn't do enough uh to to generate enough
offense so no score you don't win that's way way
way it works Mar 5 seconds and Reinhardt broke
it up the line Reinhardt Fires at the distance
and it's in the net he scores As Time expires
hug I was I was really looking forward to this
one um all summer since uh since the final and
the Panthers knock off the leavs here on the
home opener that's it hey love you Bob unreal
awesome it felt very similar to a playoff type
win um that we had all last spring especially
against these guys that it felt good ahead of
us in the standings in our division so um yeah
this one feels pretty [Applause] good they're
ready to go in Columbus stars of both squads
fans of all players the young fan Tilly this
is a young 19-year-old rookie guys like rinsky
Boon Jenner all those guys have been awesome
coming in and showing me the ropes a little bit
and help me be comfortable really quickly and I
ow those guys a lot so it's it's been great you
got to make you know some older guys who are you
know playing really well and have been around and
have that experience and then also some younger
guys who trying to learn and you know make their
Mark in the [Applause] league with the first 10
minutes 5 six 7 10 minutes we set the temple
and we play a simple and fast game all right
and no doubt who's the hungrier harder team here
tonight that's us let's come [Applause] [Music] on
[Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music]
I've been a little too crazy in
the in the diesel I'm going to be
like a little bit more calm tonight I
won I won't be running around as much
all right I'm going to blow it and then
I'm going to tell you when okay back up
for me fell here we [Applause] go got
Ros in front control over to Jenner
score rosic to control to Jenner dude
that was a sick look though you faked
him and you dropped him really fast yeah
I'm want to try with me on the wall me on
the wall oh yeah okay Wing slash cuz their
D's pinching I'll stay underneath tell him
tell him Wing or slash I'll I'll stay under so
you can go you go yeah here comes fanly plays
it to himself no race and get it he's
got marchenko going to the net marenko
go how do I say you're dude to score do I got to
learn Russian I like my I want to learn Russian on
the softly down the wall where it's intercepted
then San steps up a chance to clear
the jackets didn't do shame Marchman
scores it work Dutch out of Point hey I was in
Toronto when you bought when you brought the cup
to uh Westwood how old are you I don't know so
Dallas now outscored in the first period 13-6
this year but the second period has been their
period outscoring their opponents 14 to [Music]
six two box up and Smith save rebound
[Applause] scy hey Johnny remember that
one I got it kind of one time to two you
think I could have taken a step to make
like a onetime option or was like
that guy too high I thought he was
like right on top me I just wanted to
hand it off I don't know off chip sof
chip do sh for the lead save by Martin
and it goes in theet on the rebound I
think that's what we got to do though like
when you got that in the corner and just
Rim out like move it before they can cuz
it's still like a one hey hey so after
40 minutes down to nothing the Dallas Stars
have clawed their way back and they lead by
one shot score tip in front Tyler s and the
Stars lead four to two dropped two games in
a row and um got down too early in this
one I think that just kind of shows the
resilience that we have here and yeah never
out a game we're great with bouncing back I
think it's something that you know will try
to take with us throughout the season [Music]
[Applause] good you had a vacation like
5 days now no vacation got to work man
no you know what it was good you know what
we got see a little bit of the countryside
like in terms of like the Penguins in
Philips Island yeah it was great what
about kangaroo I saw kangaroo like in
wild or um just on the side of the road
yeah this is the National Hockey League's
first time down under Aussie people are
great uh sports fanatics luckily for us we get
to see that firsthand it's a great opportunity
for the NHL to you know grow the game here
want a lifetime experience hockey's a great
sport we'd love to turn a bunch of Australians
into hockey fans glad you could join us for what
is an historic event it's the first time in
NHL history a game has been played not only
in Australia but in the southern hemisphere
ah back at it boys come on let's have a good
game gentlemen back help him out boys what
do you want guys guyss hey hey so I should
have probably went into the corner yeah L
yeah feeds it down low schmalz to Keller in
two deep and he scores Clayton Keller has
the coyotes in front yeah got him I got
him guys sucks SL hey hey he hey nice shot I
got to tip that Nice Shot I got to tip that
hey hold up the net in the middle K scores
who got that CR 3-1 Arizona oh crer nice rip
67 going to win a face up here [Applause] yeah
3 to one coyotes dancing cooie scores yes cool
get what a goal by the youngster you know that
was one of the best goals I've ever seen the
spinner amam is one thing but then you know to
have the the patience to pull a tier forehand
and then finish it that is something you cannot
teach one of the best I've ever seen hey told
you it was an easy leag told you you geted
you know I thought it had some space and I
thought it missed the net actually but saw the
guys put their arms up so definitely felt good
to get that one and you know it was awesome
game to play in what a skill thank you it's
going to be an honor to referee you that skill
as the horn ends game one here in Melbourne 53
Arizona great atmosphere the fans
were definitely involved and you
know cheering all game and it was fun
to jump right into that NHL feel and
atmosphere from Rod labor arena in
Melbourne Australia the NHL Global
series continues you ready appr one good
luck coill that's all they call you coill
yeah nice hope you all enjoyed it good fun
all the best welcome again everybody to game
two of this weekend set the building will be
full again as the Aussies continue to show
their support and really Embrace NHL hockey
good go good touch unnecessary right now
just send it I'm going to go on the far
side I'm I'm I'm here I'm here that that
go go go Power Play winding down in tight
a chance and a goal Barrett Hatton for
the game's first goal what do you want
he last minute do something simple hey
middle up high fala feeds it right
side gets it back from kempe to Kee
one timer he scores we thought we
would have a hungry group nice job
Val that hurt I can tell we didn't know how
individuals would react or play but they they
answered the Bell they played pretty darn hard
shot score moara Jacob moara gives the Kings their
first lead but overall good experience today and
yesterday that will do it with three third period
goals the Kings defeat Arizona 3 to2 here in
the second game of the global series weekend
here in Australia when you come to a new country
you don't really know how the game's going to be
received give the the fans in the city a lot of
credit and uh respect the way that they treated
us and the way that they came and showed up for us
the coyotes salute the crowd here the king salute
the crowd it has been fantastic you see number of
NHL jersey everywhere and number of fans and the
way the people were cheering and everything that
I think that was pretty cool it's an outstanding
experience the people of Melbourne the life in
the city the energy the AFL game go fans I would
say it's an unreal [Music] [Applause] experience
ready to take the Battle of Alberta outside the
flames and Oilers in the Tim Horton's Heritage
Classic from soldout commonweal [Applause]
Stadium such a unique experience one that only you
know you maybe get to experience once or twice if
you're lucky so just trying to soak it all in the
38th outdoor game in NHL history is set to get
underway wac moving the Pu rebounds
and an inar kid has the opening goal
hey box and one stay in the box and one
let's move it no let up here he no let
up pucks keep going forward here puckets
by him though and dry is going to pick it
up and now we've got a two-on one drle
centers it Hyman shoots and [Applause]
scores you ready you ready for a cross
grease handy H hubero steps in swung
it shot Wier tipped home in front he scores and
it's conre with a deflection upstairs on Stuart
[Music]
Skinner stay away from the
puck Bud Puck doesn't want
you now the battle fully engaged
what are you going to do oh what
are you going to do I got him what is
anybody here going to do let's go this
way you're not even in my league he's got to fight
a guy like you first and show me what he's got he
a in my league not looking at much not looking at
much Fifth Line guy now Fifth Line guy keep going
boys you're playing with more Pace they can't
handle you hman kept it alive down low centering
P Conor McDavid but hooks to the corner boarded
across and now a Dish One timer rip score and Bard
through a screen and Edon extends to a 31 lead
the Oilers get it right back going to go here one
shift in time here hey you want to pick and roll y
weaves his way across the orders line gets through
Waker shoots it's stop rebound to Career he
scores the Flames get back to within one two let's
go come on man stay on it here E V Day a shot
from the point and the Edon Oilers extend to a 42
lead you're going to pull him early here there
goes markom to the bench Cho down ofri kan's got
it empty there and he scores this game's over
Edmonton f Calgary [Applause] two good job the
four game windless streak for the Oilers has ended
here at tomwell Stadium I just want to tell this
group that's guts heart and passion that we need
to play with every night you should be proud of
that effort because everybody in here is proud
of that group well done done guys [Applause]
done it's familiar but it's at the
same time you know it's it's different
tonight uh just cuz it's the first time
being back not playing here for the home
[Applause] team Eric Carlson makes his return
to the tank tonight with his third Norris
Trophy under his belt and a big penguin
in blazing across his chest which will no
doubt be strange for both Eric and his former
teammates it's a lot more than just hockey I
think you know obviously uh that's why I was
here but a big part of my life and my family's
life was was created and experienced here so
it's nice being back we have to be the most
determined team out there all the little things
that we talk about all the time that add up to
winen right it's not just about outscoring
teams it's about outplaying teams it's about
out competing teams that's the mindset that
we have to have all right let's have a good
night here starting up front we got Rusty
gy Sid on the back end me Marcus and in
that back in the building the San Jose Sharks
here in front of the home crowd still looking
for that elusive first victory of the season
and tonight they'll try and get it against a
familiar face as ek65 returns as an opponent
I've had the privilege to be able to play
with Carl for four years it's been pretty
special to be able to play alongside him
and learn from from the uh the talent that He
has and good luck to Carl but uh I hope we beat
him and Anthony declair just got into it
a little bit through right in front of you
penalty coming up right now it's going to be
two declair for a little bit too much on that
situation here Smith driving
one it scores Riley Smith to
the penthouse top shelf and a PPG for
PGH gives the pens a one- nothing lead
welcome back Eric Carlson and thank
you for five great seasons in San
Jose
[Applause]
nor Riley Smith over the line he's got Malin finds
him drops it for rust cross I Pon centering and
they score Riley Smith with a slam dunk and the
Penguins go up to zip good job Doo hey good play
eh no Panic in that game I like it so like if the
demon comes I chip it by but when he doesn't if
I give it to him then he can sell chip and we
can probably change but if I chip it we can't
change cuz then they'll just turn rust Barrels in
after the puck centers in front deflected in they
score day gentel crash in the crease the pens are
up three nothing career goal [Applause] 200 but
it's fine it's not you get by that guy you're in
now 's control off the draw across it comes the
m and a shot [Applause] scores good job hey 19
Sydney Crosby will celebrate a milestone tonight
playing in his 1200th game Crosby stepping
ahead of the pack drops it for backhander
scor the Pen's making it look too easy
easy that's called chemistry that's called
chemistry forget what's happened focus on your
next ship this team will give you chance you
got enough of you got enough in his hands it's
quick I I know what I'm not going to argue for
it I just think I did a pretty good job well
you did but it's but I did a good job doing
my job 51 seconds human man disadvantage to
kill off another one here drin put it out in
front missed by declair McDonald give go blast
door and it is a power play goal the sh jaob
mcdonal second goal for San Jose it is 8 to2
you want to do Boston or no no no B go right
back to work gel in front of redirect and chance
was denied it's loose it's in gel was walk it
away and he slides it over over the line once
more and the penguins have put up a 10 spot in
San Jose and a Victorious and emphatic start
to this California trip as the Penguins stop
the San Jose Sharks 10 to2 I'm obviously very
happy about the game that we played today and
the focus for us was to take care of our our own
business and worry about ourselves and and I I
think we executed that and did that uh you know
as well as we possibly could but at the same
time you still have a lot of people over there
that I care deeply about on a personal level
and it's not fun to see them go through what
they're going through and I know that they're
going to be okay over there and and I'm happy
that hopefully this can start something for
us Rick it really is a special night for
for hockey fans especially for the Hughes
family just the ninth time in HL history
Three Brothers have played I think it's
great for hockey I mean you know look at
the the talent of those three guys how
close they are as brothers and how how much
they love each other and how much they want
each other to do so well is is really the
story for me it's it's a very close-knit
family tonight at Rogers Arena Queen Hughes has
company in fact he's outnumbered Brothers Jack
and luuk are in town you know for one kid to
get the NHL it's really hard so for three in
one family to you know all be playing in one
game tonight that's really exciting I think
we should have a lot of fun it's it's pretty cool
I would be happy if I would be their parents for
sure soak it in Jim and Allen Hughes you done
good yeah it's exciting of course first time
playing Luke in the NHL and obviously really cool
but for me I'm just trying to you know temper my
emotions and just try to focus on what I need
to control 200 foot game pockets in deep here
good communication let's come in after that
first period with a with a lead here here we
go come on as special and exciting as it is to
see the Three Brothers on the the same ice in
the National Hockey League it's about winning
everybody going here come on everybody here
everybody all right white black great jump off
that face off real good jump off that draw BR
is a two-on one the other way R it Brett moves in
shot scores do it do it and the devil's lead one
nothing 24 New Jersey got a minor tripping big
kill here big kill I win this play and go back
door now to the right Circle for besser again to
Pon back to besser right Circle L shot tip they
score JT Miller at the top of the crease knocks
it home I M good plays good plays we got to get
into the body Hugh up Jack Hughes spins away
from Tyler Myers Hughes to the front here's
hold he answers and the devils are back out in
front good for boys Jag is the first Hughes on
the board the middle from the middle of the corner
you go to the net having ball from the blue line
to the front score Jack Hughes TS in what a play
K hey nice mu in hey good kick goodick good draw
Jack good job Curtis Lazar picks it up wrist one
in front of Def flex and they score Michael mlow
diving after the loose Puck and it is four to R
just's got to start making some hard plays here
big block big block there come on Teddy here we go
come on Teddy bler sets up shot from the near side
puts one in front tipped on go by Garland rebound
Joshua scores Dakota Joshua able to Coral that
Puck and slide it in make it four to two let's
go hey hy shoot off the wall hey 94 right right
right feet moving feet moving feet moving feet
moving come on back back stick down stick down
get ready for him go B go get ready for hogy hogy
hogy 40 seconds left before the period horn comes
Jack to the front to fully sticked it but it rules
up top and Luke Hughes rips it in so now Jack and
Luke have both scored against Quin sh Luke good
job you guys good job boy Jack boy to and that's
going to do it for period number two let's let's
try something different right we get on the four
check win the draw if not then you play normal
okay if you want just something to think about
here we go come on come on best get back into
it okay I'm coming off the wall I might drop it
to you middle middle Hogs go to the neck more than
that dumps it into the near Corner Sean ther to it
hit into the end boards by hoglander Miller gets
it loose in front B to the back hand he scores
just a strong for check and support leads to that
goal to make it 5-3 back back back back back let's
go let's go let's play discipline boys discipline
here's patteron back to Hughes Quin Hughes R shot
deflected in front by Sam laferty and it's a one
goal game a good shift on that last one too we'll
get we'll get that back all night if we play that
one guy in front hey get to the net hog Hugh nice
move in the line try to shot that was blocked
gets it again F puts it on goal rebound scor
[Music] Canucks are back to square three minutes
15 seconds to [Applause] go we need everybody
everybody on board here final minute of the
third period it comes to the blue line that's
the support we need right there sends it down
low poot to the Blue Line Paul shoots def Jer
brat bangs it in with 30 three seconds to
play and that'll do it Jasper brat is the
hero for the devils in this one as he gets the
winning goal us to take that how he did that was
massive two points for us the Hughes Brothers
their fingerprints were all over this game all
three of us are just just try to get better every
day and um you know work and perfect our craft as
much as we can so haven't really let it sink
in yet but two days going to dinner and and
hanging out has been uh great for our family
and you know it's it's nice we got the win so
I'm sure they're appreciating it more than I am
right now but um yeah it's very cool I'm sure
know you know looking back at next couple days
or months or whatever you know it'll be a cool
one